okay so now I have no comments all of
your comments are gone okay literally
everyone's comments and questions are
gone so you're gonna have to type them
in again I'm sorry about that
um opinions on the nurse Jamie uplift I
don't know what that is I do have my
laptop here so I could look it up if it
works yes Jamie I don't know how much
information I can get on it quickly
there massaging PG roller yeah I think I
answered a question on massaging at the
very beginning basically I think facial
massages they could potentially push out
fluid that builds up in your face I
don't know if increasing circulation is
really like a really important thing
because like lots of things increase
circulation like running exercise all of
that increases circulation I don't think
you need to roll out your face to do
that plus exercise there's tons of other
benefits as well so it's like a like
five for one sort of deal um yeah I
think just from looking at this
massaging stones I think it's just a
massager really unique rhythmic rolling
action yeah that mm yeah that doesn't
really strike me as a really like
rigorous sort of hum claim yeah I think
it's probably just a massaging tool like
yeah I think it's a it's just a hyped up
massaging tool am I worried about
antioxidants oxidizing on my skin not
really they're meant to oxidize they're
sort of like sacrificial shield so if
they oxidize they're helping their
oxidizing instead of my skin oxidizing
so overall a good thing and Ajaib rule
rollers do anything other than having a
cooling effect yet possibly the massage
effect um
I don't think they do much apart from
massage though and how good a massage is
is still like really up for debate if
you don't go to Hut then maybe it's
quite nice and it's quite pleasant plus
it's like yeah the pleasantness itself
is probably a good thing too
yeah in terms of skin benefits I'm not
really convinced about massage yeah oil
based moisturizer under sunscreen um so
in my sunscreen and makeup video I've
linked a study where they put
moisturizer under and over sunscreen
under sunscreen was definitely better
than over sunscreen so if you have an
under sunscreen it decreased water
resistance of the sunscreen which isn't
great but if you put it over sunscreen
it actually removes the sunscreen it's
almost like a cream cleanser yeah so
moisturizers definitely should go under
sunscreen in terms of oil-based um I
would probably try to minimize all base
moisturizer because it is going to like
decrease the the water resistance a lot
more because the oil won't sink into
your skin and won't evaporate unlike
water um yes I think that's the main
concern um if you have if we have
prescription as a lake acid in Australia
I think so I think that's definitely one
that's over-the-counter I don't know if
it's prescription um Phoenicia I think
it's called yeah plus there's also the
one from as clear but I hate the texture
of it it feels like PVA glue when I put
it on yeah I haven't really been
impressed by azelaic acid so far and I
think it's because as a lake acid you
need a really high concentration of it I
think it's like between 10 and
twenty-something percent and I think
that just means that the whole product
like it's like a chance to a fifth of
the product
it's azelaic acid and it doesn't have a
nice texture and so when you put it on
your skin it's just like not pleasant to
use at all so I think that's my main
issue with it the studies do look pretty
good but yeah apart from that it's also
kind of stings my skin a bit I don't
know if it's because of the treasurer
Nolan yeah you're only 20 so the lines
are from bending your neck um
unfortunately mechanical wrinkles like
from repeated bending they're gonna
happen um I think the best thing to do
is probably sunscreen so the things that
contribute to a wrinkle if I remember
correctly is firstly the fact that you
have your skin is weaker so things like
photo aging chronological aging and also
just repeater bending so if you address
both of those as best you can then
they'll reduce the lines and wrinkles oh
Alinta says the 20% as like acid is easy
to get in chemistry house is that the
fir nation one the over-the-counter
Phoenicia so like you just ask the
chemist for it I'm sure she'll reply in
a sec um from bending yeah yeah so I
think if you try to reduce yeah as clear
okay
yeah that's the UM that's the PVA glue
one um yeah so if you try to reduce the
bending and you try to protect your your
neck as well as possible from aging so
things like using tratan Owen vitamin C
all of those sunscreen definitely
sunscreen then the lines should be a
little bit less relationship between
diet and acne
um it's complicated I've been meaning to
write a post on that it's complicated
there is very weak evidence on all full
Matala gist and doctors the evidence is
very weak so far it's like there's just
a lot of conflicting information from
studies so for example they thought
there was a link between dairy and acne
and then it turns out like the link is
mostly between low-fat acne and sorry
low-fat dairy and acne um but not
high-fat dairy and acne so yeah the
whole thing is just all over the place
um my personal opinion is that it
probably depends on the person a lot as
well so anecdotally I've heard lots of
people who have cut out dairy and their
acnes cleared up I've heard lots of
people who have cut out acne and they're
sorry cut out dairy and their acne is
like the same I've heard of people who
have drunk on water and then their acnes
cleared up Drunken lots of water no
change that to the acne so I think
there's like a lot of factors involved
especially with anecdotal evidence so if
you start drinking a whole bunch of
water for example and your acne clears
up it could because you're getting more
water it could be because instead of
getting water sorry instead of eating a
whole bunch of junk food you're now
drinking a ton of water and so you can't
fit as much junk food into your junk
food into your stomach um yeah so I
think it's just really hard to tell at
the moment and so far the like bigger
clinical trials there's just not much
info and the info is all conflicting so
in terms of data and acne um I think
that's why a lot of dermatologists
aren't really comfortable recommending
things if you've ever talked to like
doctors who are quite serious about
their doctoring they are really into
really high quality evidence like
skincare studies with ten people like
that they just won't even look at that
they won't base anything on that they
need like massive clinical trials on
like 200 300 people and so far there
just isn't that sort of clinical trial
on diet and acne or there's like one or
two and um diet is just really it's
really hard to design diet studies um I
can't remember where I was reading an
article on a diet study and um like
someone who was trying to design a diet
study and it was
just really difficult I think it was
like a vitamin C chewing gum or
something it might have been on a
science-based medicine which is one of
the blog's I really love reading about
it's like general medicine it's very
into critical thinking but basically
they were designing a this is a while
ago so I might have gotten the details
wrong I believe they were designing a
study where they were trying to give
vitamin C to people and seeing what the
effect was and they were trying to
design some way of ensuring that the
people actually had like took the
vitamin C and I think they ended up
doing it they put the vitamin C into a
chewing gum and then they gave each
person a calendar and so every day the
person would chew the gum and stick it
on the calendar and that was how they
had proof that the person Ashley took
the vitamin C so your clinical trials on
diet it's really hard to run because if
they're trying the vitamin C again maybe
they'll end up drinking more water less
water maybe it's the water that changes
it yes I think diet and acne it's a
really really tricky area I will I am
trying to write something on it so far
yeah it's really quite overwhelming um
yeah so in the meantime Eric and just
like try out different things and see
what works for you
yeah by the time we have strong evidence
it will be will be like 70 hopefully
acne will be our acne will be over
although some people are pretty unlucky
and they get after you till there until
they die of old age um is applying amino
acids topically useful generally amino
acids are just humectant moisturizes
your skin can't really take them in acid
and turn it into anything yeah it just
doesn't really happen that way
um-hmm when scrutinizing a products
ingredients how far down the list do I
go before the concentrations are likely
to be inconsequential and depends on the
product generally about five depends on
the ingredients as well so there are
lots of ingredients that work at low
concentrations so things like trash'
Nolan yeah
um people with teenagers with bad acne
my recommendations would probably be if
it's really bad so your dermatologist
generally the things that dermatologists
might prescribe accutane spironolactone
so those are both oral drugs benzoyl
peroxide treasurer Nolan or adapt lien
so one of the rationals some
dermatologists still prescribe topical
antibiotics as well so starts with II
can't remember name anyway yeah um
erythromycin yes so they tend to
prescribe things like that um I I can't
remember which one's the most effective
anymore I think a keychain is
ridiculously effective but it is pretty
hardcore yes so if it's really bad talk
to the dermatologist maybe try some of
the over-the-counter things so the
benzoyl peroxide the directional aids
maybe even an H egg and see how that
goes
um does the $100 all the work better
than a five-dollar roller I don't know I
would suspect probably not will micellar
water remove mineral sunscreen well
depends on the sunscreen depends on the
micelle water yeah so talked about
eyebags
earlier is it true that ascorbic acid
absorb in seconds um I'm sure some of it
absorbs within seconds but um earlier I
saying the absorption curve for things
tends to be like this so like some of it
will absorb early and then some of it
will slowly absorb yeah so absorbing
within seconds I'm sure some limited
source within seconds but I don't know
how much it's hit bad for skin what do I
think about saunas um depends on your
skin heat is definitely bad for rosacea
and I think it's probably bad for a lot
of sensitive skin conditions as well
depends on the amount of heat yeah I
think extreme temperatures either hot or
cold not great for skin pretty
irritating and the other thing that he
does is it can also start dissolving a
lot more of the oils and natural
moisturizing factors in your skin and
then wash it away as well I'll
clindamycin for acne yeah that's another
one do the home LED skin light therapy
device work um I think it depends on
which one you're talking about I
mentioned a bit about light therapy
earlier in the context of acne so
different devices put out different
wavelengths of light they put out
different bands of wavelengths or some
of them put out a whole bunch some of
them put out just a few narrow ones they
put out different intensities as well so
I think it depends on all of those
things
um which branch of chemistry am i
interested in besides cosmetic chemists
resew my PhD was in well everyone's PhD
is on like a bunch of different topics
mine mostly covered synthetic medicinal
chemistry some peptide chemistry yeah so
I've always been interested in medicinal
chemistry because it's like how things
interact with your body I've been
getting more interested in physical
chemistry as well so things like how how
emulsions work so how how sir parks how
you can make different and different
types of creams and stuff like that yeah
how my cats all they're lovely yeah
they're lovely
yeah Escalade has a bad texture that's
why you wanted to know prescription
options try the Phoenicia I believe it
is over-the-counter like you have to ask
the chemist for it and maybe ring them
and say and then save you need a
prescription do I like the azelaic acid
from the ordinary I haven't tried it yet
I don't think it's available in
Australia it's the bubble clay mask
harmful for skin
I don't think so the bubbles it's like
just bubbles of oxygen so I don't think
they like really exciting I think the
rest of it is just a moisturizing mask
hmm what do I think is missing in the
skincare community that a potential
skincare enthusiast can make I don't
know that's a really hard question
that's a really hard question that's
mean um hmm yeah I don't know I will
have to think about that I think maybe
some of the things I really like reading
about are people's personal experiences
with skincare so things like how it
changed them like how it's this form of
therapy for them some sometimes I really
like reading those personal stories as
well of course reviews are great like
having more reviews of products seeing
reviews of products on different types
of skin and stuff like that yeah um it's
mascara or eyelash glue harmful for the
eyes mascara if you don't take it off
completely it is linked to infections so
little flakes can get into your eye and
irritate it and then um yeah eyelash
glue I'm not entirely sure I think
eyelash glue is probably the same thing
of course there's also in latex in some
eyelash glue which some people are
allergic to which is really bad if
you're allergic if you're not allergic
it's fine um is it true that lycopene
can be absorbed through skin um I'm not
sure
when I did my antioxidant post I think I
looked up I mostly looked at reviews on
antioxidants in skincare and from memory
I
don't think they really mention lycopene
um yes I'm not sure lycopene is a pretty
big molecule though I'm not sure how
much the antioxidant really needs to
absorb I think yeah I'm not entirely
sure about that one is water-based
vitamin C serum that's gone bad actually
harmful for skin there's I don't think
it is the reasons I don't think it is is
there is one company that actually sells
a serum that is the dehydroascorbic acid
I think that's the name it's been awhile
since I've read about it and they market
that as good for skin there's also the
fact that there's lots of studies done
on vitamin C over like periods of weeks
and stuff and it seems to be it seems to
improve the skin so I think it's
probably yeah that's probably okay um
can I talk about my university journey
how did I make the decision to do
post-grad uh-huh that's oh wow um that
could be a while um so I did really well
in high school um so I got into the
course I wanted at the time of course I
was seventeen I didn't know what the
hell I wanted to do back when I was in
high school I had some really good
science teachers so I was really
interested in science but I actually
really really enjoyed arts like I really
enjoyed doing English I really enjoyed
the creative writing so I ended up doing
a science in law degree um in Australia
during a combined science and law degree
means you do five years your first three
years of science your last two and then
during those you do the equivalent of
first year law as well in terms of
subjects then you go into second year
law well then you have a choice you
either do honors and science or you can
go straight to law after you finish
honors you can go back to law and they
finish off law and become a lawyer and
then if you have signs and law usually
they tell you that you should become a
patient attorney um so I wanted to I
wanted to sign some more thinking I'd
become a corporate lawyer um I started
working in a law firm in second year I
got really depressed I was like crying
on the train to to
work the law firm was working for it was
working on some like pretty horrible
unethical kind of well to me it seemed
like it was like a epical dilemma sort
of case I wasn't really doing much I was
like an undergrad so I was like
photocopying things filing papers that
sort of thing and that was already like
really bad so I realized I didn't have
what it took to become a corporate
lawyer I know lots of people are good at
like compartmentalizing stealth I am not
so I couldn't I just couldn't do it
um so I did honours and then I really
enjoyed my project and so I decided to
do a post-grad so that's how I ended up
in post-grad during post-grad um I
discovered that I didn't really love
science that much to do research to like
constantly find out that my things
didn't work in medicinal chemistry
there's this thing where like one in
every million or something molecules
ends up as a drug and so that was that
attrition rate was just a bit too a bit
too much for me and there was also a lab
accident during near the end of my PhD
and so that that really cemented the
fact that even though I love science I
didn't love it enough to die in a fire
because someone else stuffed up um sorry
um there's also a lot of talk about how
hard academia is and like what the
conditions are like if you look up there
are lots of people who have done lots of
great articles on this and I just
realised I didn't want to be in that
sort of climate and I didn't really do
that so yeah that's yeah that's my
university story I guess um
[Music]
do I take any supplements for my skin no
I don't I do take supplements for other
things so I take a lot of magnesium
because I found that it makes my muscles
less or after exercise that's the main
one I take also vitamin G of course mmm
does EGS skincare work I'm not entirely
sure I believe there are a few studies
on it yeah
glutathione in skincare serums is that
as powerful as vitamin C I don't think
it is there are Studies on on how well
it works yeah but I don't think it's
quite as it's not as well studied as
vitamin C for sure does taking oral
collagen do something for the skin I
have a video on that it seems to do a
little bit of something I don't know how
much it it doesn't do that much so
depending on what your budget is whether
you can find a cheap one that sort of
thing how much you're willing to spend
for that little extra boost it might be
worth it favorite vitamin C product DIY
serum yeah although I am pretty lazy so
I do just tend to put a pinch of vitamin
C into stuff is it true that peptides
our scam because they have large
molecules um I don't think so there are
some studies on peptides there aren't in
many studies on peptides I think the
reason is because peptides tend to be
patented and so there's not much of
incentive for other companies to
research it there isn't much of there's
like just a lot of barriers to
independent organizations researching it
as well so they'd have to buy the
peptide which would be more expensive
because it's patient hood when they test
it or be for a company that will profit
from it so again like trying to justify
doing it is a bit harder um so I think
that's why there's less Studies on them
I don't think it's entirely and there
are some independent studies I think
that have found benefits of peptides um
it's blue light that the skin I have a
post coming up on that it's not that bad
it's bad in some situations so I think
for darker skin it can darken
pigmentation in terms of skin damage
it's really really tiny compared to UV
um a pinch of vitamin C I'm using um
pure ascorbic acid it's the same one
that I use like I bought a giant jar of
it it's the same one I use for my DIY
serum and the recipe for that is on my
blog I should probably do a video of
that as well yeah a pinch it's a bit
risky putting a pinch in things um it's
not a very like it's very easy to overdo
it cuz like you only need a tiny tiny
amount of vitamin C um so it is
definitely risky um I don't recommend
doing it if you're not sure what you're
doing and if your skin is sensitive to
acids I haven't actually used that much
vitamin C since I started using
tretinoin I think if I did it now I
would probably yeah it would probably be
a sting a bit
yeah well thank you um yeah what's the
time all right um I should probably go
to sleep
um yeah thanks for everyone who joined
how to reapply sunscreen at midday and
that's in my sunscreen and makeup video
depends on whether or not you need to do
it um yeah I don't think you need to
wash stuff off before you reapply yeah
um yeah all righty thanks everyone who
joined me and asked questions I hope you
found it useful I will save this and
upload it and yeah